how to play against the Kings Indian
defense last time we talked about the
sloth defense but this time I will show
you what to do if opponent displaying
the Kings Indian defense very nice way
of handling the Kings Indian defense so
Dee for you are going to be playing this
from the white side okay Knight f6 c4 g6
Knight to c3 and at this moment we don't
know it's a Kings Indian defense yet we
don't know yet because it can still turn
to a different opening here if you place
the move d5 if you place the move d5 it
will be a guru in filth defense okay but
we are talking about this opening today
Bishop g7 as soon as he plays Bishop g7
we know that that is which opening
Kings Indian defense okay so remember as
soon as he plays Bishop g7 as soon as
you see this right in the first three
moves that means this is Kings Indian
defense okay not names oh is different
now it's not an easy opening to play
against because there are a lot of
different lines a lot of sharp lines
perhaps but I will show you a very
simple system that will help you to get
advantage okay night goes on f3
developing the knight now he plays
castle and now Bishop to g5 take a look
how white is setting up his pieces d6
III so the opening name is King's Indian
but the name of the system anybody
familiar with the system maybe or hurt
the name of it the name for the system
for white what's the name of the system
no okay yeah I'm not sure if you know
this but you will know it after today's
lesson this is called smyslov Petrosyan
system okay named after two very strong
players okay world champion and Smith
Slav and Petrosyan they're the ones who
play this okay this system was developed
by them and I have been playing this
system for a very very long time okay
and with some very very good results now
the point of this move is when they play
the Kings Indian is aiming for more
attacking type of positions so but when
we play this system with eatery's we try
to make this bishop more blocked so
bishop is not as active okay we try to
you know steer away from the complicated
lines but play more like solid solid
setup here
now night bt7 the point of this movie is
to try to play perhaps be five you
develop your bishop on YouTube
now they play c6 is another useful move
here and now and now here most people
will just cancel here but you will play
a different move the better move here
okay and the better move here is Queen
to c2 because when you play Queen c2 you
will set up a very nice a trap here h6
Bishop on h4 g5 Bishop g3 and now black
plays Knight h5 now white to play do you
see the tactical idea that will help you
to win material or even checkmate him if
is not careful here something about this
night here this Knight is loose
something about this night okay
something about it what can you do here
huh I see a couple of hands let's see
here yes Knight takes g5 he is
sacrificing his knight and if he takes
you take his Knight at the end of this
little combination now you want a pond
okay and you have very nice position you
want a pond so excellent and if you
makes a blunder and takes your bishop
what are you going to do to win this
game immediately
and better you have something much
better than take it okay something much
better yes very good Queen takes h7
checkmate it's a long-range move and it
will be a checkmate okay so remember
this tactical idea so in this position
black starts chasing around your bishop
and as soon as he puts it there you go
Knight g5 if it takes the bishop
checkmate
if it takes we take okay
now another idea here another way game
can develop here if black plays c5
attacking the central pawn you push the
pawn to d5 and again they try to chase
your Bishop every time they try to chase
your Bishop there is a chance for you to
do some tactical idea you retreat they
chase the bishop you go here Knight h5
Bishop d3 I hit twice this position and
both times my opponent blundered two
different types of blunders
so one opponent played a five and this
is a mistake why
why this is a mistake huh now he is
losing at least upon and he will
technically have a losing position here
yes yes pissant correct now he takes
back with a bishop and now
what can you do here
an idea that will help you to win upon
actually 2 pounds at least here at least
2 pounds here continue excellent very
good Bishop d6 look he's sacrificing his
bishop and if he captures the follow-up
is yes discovery check he takes back and
we pick up the Queen you see how that
works very nice idea let's do it again
so in this position my opponent played
'if I've and you take he takes M Bishop
d6 one more time I want to demonstrate
that this is a very very nice tactic
because if it takes what do we do
when you're very good you have a
question same thing doesn't change
anything still check takes bish page
seven my opponent right here when I took
right here he already realize the
problem and it was a good player
international masters right here he
realized yeah he made he made a mistake
and he took on g3
he took on g3 and now very important in
between move check okay in between move
you have here because if you just
capture back then he will capture back
so you have to do a very nice in-between
idea yes with a check you could but then
he just takes he just takes you need
something else yes
pawn takes f7 check very good now rook
takes and pawn takes g3 very nice
that's tidying now I and I went on to
win the game because I just played
Bishop to g4 Bishop d5 extra pawn and a
lot of a lot of pressure okay very nice
position okay
the other game that I want was my
opponent here played 97 you know
thinking that this might be okay this
opponent was also good player to tell
2300 federating player he played Knight
d7 but now this is a blunder again why
why is this a blunder let's think okay
so we can find the tactical idea again
that will help us win material
what's the idea here think a little bit
more because it's not so simple this
idea it looks very natural but you have
to go a little bit deeper on the line
now what can you do here again opponent
has a loose piece here and that loose
piece is this night here you know and
you have to think about what can you do
to do something about that loose piece
yes
95 excellent if not not 95 night 95 yes
95 now if he takes with this pawn you
just go Queen hh5 threating mate and
threaten to win so you you're doing
great here you're winning
so he will take on g3 your Bishop
expecting next to take your knight so
what can you do now
yes yeah
yeah but then he takes it takes your
rook when you lose your rook - I mean
it's not yeah you lose your rook as well
yeah but you lose a lot you lose like
Knight rook Bishop you you'll be down a
lot in that line okay
so don't don't want to do that right now
just just play simple play simple yes
how do we play simple here you could go
[ __ ] page seven but let's do that a
little later okay that move it doesn't
it's not as strong right now to it right
away
simple simple play needed here yes your
rook is hanging you will lose lose the
rook here yes of course of course age
span
you get the H file is now open now your
H file is opened you can attack on it so
now he takes and now it's very important
to play this move right now because
otherwise his King is going to escape
he's going to move the rook away and
escape so you want to make a move so he
doesn't escape now yes
then he goes rook e8 see then he goes
Rukia you know you don't want it to go
Rukia because once he goes rook e8 any
time you check him he is going to go to
f8 and he's going to find a safety area
there okay
he is going to find that safety area -
so what are we going to do here so he
doesn't go George
yes
that would work that would work but if
he blunders like this that would be
brilliant yes that would be excellent
George but the problem is he takes with
a bishop and then he brings the defender
in you know so that's that's a nice idea
that would have worked if the bishop
wasn't there that would have been a
brilliant way of to force the checkmate
okay so now we need to force the King to
the area force them to do with a corner
yes
remember we have to move his king there
yeah how can you move him think
aha check now he goes here
my opponent saw this he saw this idea
but he thought in our next move he's
just going to put a knight eh he's just
gonna put a knight there and he will be
safe but he meets the idea he meets my
idea that he might not be able to do
that this is a you know not a easy move
again this is not a easy move I know
you're thinking about just meeting him
here but you need to find a very good
move here okay not an easy move here so
let's see I see a couple of hands here
correct answer George yes correct 94 the
idea to control the f6 square and this
is the move that my opponent missed it
because normally you look at the
concrete lines you know bringing the
Queen in like you bring the Queen e'en
it doesn't really work he goes here it
doesn't really work so that's why we
have to go
94 here and now this works let's see why
now Knight f6 continue
Knight X on f6 now pawn takes f6
and now
and now you got to get your queen in
right queen is ready to go we're better
more active more active you want to be
close to where the action is so you can
mate him you know this is the king right
we want a king to be aware where do you
want your queen to be yes of course h5
yes and now you threatened to go check
and Queen h7 mate check Queen h7 mate so
he goes cook e8 and now what you going
to do after he goes through key eight we
have lot of again a lot of discovery
checks but if they're not going to
result in to win you need something
better here to do something better here
something so his King is completely
exposed here what can we do here
because he's got a lot of defenders you
know yes
yes but then he goes here and when you
about to meet him he escapes okay so
that's what he's trying to he's trying
to escape here that's why it's not so
what can you do here instead yes in the
back very back yes
very strong
yes very strong because now you move
your bishop he is getting mated here no
choice for him you move the bishop he is
getting mated now okay he is now he does
anything yes anything let's say and now
time to mate how yes and he goes here
several ways to mate here several ways
now yes and what is that that is
checkmate indeed excellent excellent job
okay that's how you meet in this line
okay so let's make sure we go back so
you can see this idea again again let's
start on the very beginning okay let's
see if you can reach this position from
a very very beginning see if you were
paying attention when I show you this
theory okay the first move I need
somebody who can say the first move for
white what was the first move yes second
move second move third move third move
fourth move yes
now next move
yes
f/4g five and what is the name of this
opening first of all which opening is
this Kings Indian defense correct what's
the name of the system you remember who
remembers the system I mentioned to you
the Kings Indian defense is the name of
the opening but what is the system it is
smyslov Petrossian yes very both very
very strong players miss love and
petrosyan okay very positional and they
they were the ones who really play the
system a lot and that's why they named
after them so now see five and your
Center is attacked we got a what we got
to do D 5 H 6 now we just need to
retreat right yes Oh
retreat yeah H 4
g-53 three-tier night h 5 bishop
develops on d3 and now knight to
disagree already checked if I but Knight
to d7 years do you see the idea here
what is the idea now to win to win this
game
yes night dots later that's later this
is the tactic time okay where you can
expose the king yes absolutely if it
takes to the pawn then we just take on
h5 so it's not good so he has to take
back with this piece on g3 continue he
takes your knight remember it's
important that we push his King on h8
right now because otherwise we're not
going to be able to do it later so we
have to push him right now and how are
we going to do that okay
and now the difficult move remember a
lot of a lot of suggestions here a lot
of you were trying to suggest the move
but what is the move here to prevent you
know to make sure that if the knight
ever reaches there what are you going to
do correct answer yes 94 now Queen h5 is
coming so he plays Knight f6 now what do
you do now
absolutely you take tonight and if it
takes now which piece comes in into the
attack where absolutely now you're ready
to go Bishop g6 check rook checkmate so
he goes rookie eight and now remember
when the rook moves don't think about
checkmate again try to eliminate all the
defenders okay all the defenders F yeah
that's f7
quint exertion excellent now he goes
through key seven and now several ways
to make but what would be the simplest
way to do it simplest way to finish this
game here yes
yeah 5 g 6 anywhere okay it's same thing
he goes here only move and now a queen
h7 I have a rock you have a rock so be
careful ok 7 checkmate
ok excellent very good very good
now at the end I want to show you we're
going to have some practice ok practice
games as well I want to show you one
really cool position white to play it
looks like white is in trouble because
black is just going to Queen this
without any resistance and if you try to
create your own path bound you're just
really late you know here you're just
late just goes here and stops your pawns
yeah so that's not going to work so
backing is closer but there is a very
nice way for you here to make a draw
here very unique idea ok you unique way
to make a draw here let's see ok so
what's the idea here very tricky idea
very tricky you probably never seen this
idea before but it's a very very
beautiful way of making a draw here so
let's see I see a couple of hands here
but you sure you have this ok I is it
unique idea okay go ahead take a shot
oh that's not gonna work
look you need one one two three four
five six by the time you do that he's
going to Quinn here is one two three
four so that that plum not gonna work
okay let's see you go here I go here you
go here I go here you're just way too
far you know so you're like you I can't
even make a pass here and you sticking
out Cashman let's say I pass yeah you go
here then I Quinn that's that's how much
behind you are you know that I give you
a pass and I still a queen so that's not
going to work but we have something else
we can try to do here very nice idea
is it the special idea okay give a shot
okay King g3 okay what is he trying to
do here let's see a tree g3 I push aha
that's called the self stalemate idea
okay you brought your king all the way
there and you close the door with g3
here so the King got trapped and this is
a self still mate idea very good job
excellent okay so okay anything he does
anything what do you want to do instead
yes
I understand but the problem is it's
still made there's no more moves we can
make the game ended here with a withdraw
because it's a stalemate idea okay if
you had a queen here then you would have
had the checkmate here say we don't work
but this is just a just a stalemate self
still made idea
okay everyone good job we have about
twenty minutes we're going to do casual
play okay